[Music]
my name is John Murray I'm a product
manager here at Google cloud and I work
on what used to be called the cloud
services platform we didn't change this
session but we did change the name on
Tuesday so it's now called anthos and
I'm gonna talk a little bit today about
policy management for that so we're
gonna go through some of the tools that
we have in the open source software that
we're shipping that allows you to manage
corporate policies governance policies
and those sorts of things on top of
anthos as well as talk about some of the
tooling we built on top of that open
source to make that easier particularly
when you're running a hybrid or multi
cloud environment we've got a lot of
distributed computing out there so let's
get started for those who did not see
the announcement on Tuesday and those is
our application modernization platform
for the hybrid multi cloud world and the
idea here is that we have services a
marketplace and a control plane that
lives in the cloud here on GCP and is a
central place for you to manage all that
stuff and that fans out to a bunch of
different compute environments either
say running on GCP running on prem with
gk on prem or other clouds the basis of
that are a number of building blocks and
so it starts kind of at the bottom with
the infrastructure operator so I've got
kind of that role here as somebody
working on Google Cloud but that could
be infrastructure that's in any kind of
environment right it could be another
cloud could be on Prem and so that's
stuff like storage and networking VMs
and other kind of primitive building
blocks of infrastructure and that found
that's the foundation of anthos on top
of that we have a kubernetes
distribution so gke and the cloud GK on
Prem on Prem and
that allows you to have kind of a
uniform computing layer with a uniform
API across all of these environments
that's kind of the first level where
policies come into play and where you
can start controlling that environment
and then above that one of the other
layers that we have is sto which is our
service mesh in open source but also
something that we manage on gke and that
we're building to lea around such as the
cloud services mesh which is in alpha
right now and that really allows you to
think about your services kind of at the
HTTP l7 layer abstract those out and
think about a traffic as a graph and a
kind of micro services environment
there's a number of policies there that
have to do with how services talk to one
another how traffic is routed and we'll
get into that in a little bit there are
many other pieces of anthos here that
you can bring to the table I'm going to
talk mostly about these but we have
things like cloud run and came native
for running sort of server lists
containers although the servers are
still there as many of you know and you
know things like our marketplace various
other bits and pieces in addition to
that I'm gonna talk today about anthos
config management so that is a way to
knit all of this stuff together and
provide you with kind of a single
administrative experience for talking to
all these different platforms in a kind
of distributed environment and the way
that that works is that we use the
kubernetes native policy formats which
effectively are putting all of those
policies in code so that you can analyze
them so that they're repeatable and so
that the
the policies that you apply to this
environment are auditable reproducible
transactional and self-healing what I
mean by that is if you put all this
stuff in a git repository you get a lot
of advantages of source control so you
can go and look at everything in one
place the changes that you make to a
particular cluster or the multi cluster
environment are reproducible across new
clusters that you bring in or new
service meshes that you bring in a git
repository is transactional so that when
you make a commit you can roll that back
you can roll it forward you know exactly
what was changed by when and by whom
and then the self-healing aspects of
this or that we are looking at these git
repositories bringing down the
configuration all these different places
and then constantly reconciling that in
the local environments to make sure that
if things drift out of line then we
bring them back in and I'll talk a
little bit more about that so let's talk
about the policies that are available to
you the idea with the anthos is for us
mainly to work off of open source so
there's a lot of open source stuff that
you can do on these platforms as well as
a lot of stuff that we can do inside the
infrastructure so to the degree that
we've needed our customers to operate on
these platforms we've gone into the
upstream open source and tried to
contribute to some of these things
alongside many other folks who work on
the platforms for kubernetes that means
things like access control so kubernetes
has a role based access control system
allows you to define who's allowed to do
what on any given cluster who can deploy
pods who can make changes to policies
networking there is a number of
different networking mechanisms in there
things like network policy which allow
you to define routing between individual
pods on a cluster we support that in gke
as well as on Prem now their partners at
Tye Guerra who
make the container networking interface
for Calico and then security and
isolation so you can do things like set
up a pod security policy in kubernetes
allows you to define what a container is
allowed to do in terms of interacting
with the host environment and that
creates isolation through things like
name spaces as well as isolating the
containers from kind of the underlying
environment to ensure that they only
have the access that they need and
they're not able to kind of break out of
that and move across boundaries on the
use geo side one of the the great
policies there is traffic routing right
so is do is something that you can use
to think about your services at kind of
the the level of the inbound traffic
that you have you set up a gateway and
bring in your ingress traffic and then
route that to micro services using
things like waiting setting up things
like mutual TLS so that all of the
different services within your service
match are communicating in an encrypted
fashion and you can do things like
service to service access control and so
if you have a flat network where
everything is talking to one another
that might be fine but it might mean
that an attacker can you know
compromised one of your services and go
look at something that they're not
supposed to be so services service
access control is a way to ensure that
only services that should be talking to
other services or sending traffic around
and then there's a whole bunch of
extensibility in sto so there's a mixer
component in there that allows people to
bring in plugins and so you can do
things like plug-in telemetry but you
can also do things like plug-in
authorization and
there's a number of different things in
the community that we support there and
then when we talk about the
infrastructure we're really talking
about kind of the underlying stuff so on
GCP that stuff like GCB services so you
may have your clusters backed by storage
that's sitting on GCS bucket or you may
have your services backed by a sequel
database like cloud sequel things like
firewalls secure images and even the
cluster flags that are on your cluster
and so we want all of this stuff to be
able to be declarative and what I mean
by that is you can show up and tell us
exactly how you want this environment to
look you can put constraints around that
to say these are the types of things
that we want our developers or our
administrators to be able to do and then
enforce all of that in code just like
you enforce things when you build
applications and so shift some of that
compliance further up into the
infrastructure pipeline and then give
you the tooling to kind of make that a
lot easier to manage so I talked a
little bit about API server flags that's
a really important piece of security on
kubernetes there's a lot of things that
you can set up a cluster to do that are
relatively insecure and so it's not
sufficient just to come in and change
the configuration on top of your cluster
you often have to think about the
configuration of the cluster itself one
of the advantages we have gke on Prem
and that kubernetes distribution is that
those clusters are built declaratively
and so you're able to specify cluster
actually as a kubernetes object with all
of those flags set and so you have a
reproducible way of stamping out
clusters that's secure and you can
validate that by looking at the code
access control I mentioned already our
back is I think the the best and most
widely used way of managing that on
kubernetes but there are a number of
other ways you can manage access control
Network policy I mentioned resource
quota is a way to set up policies about
who can do what in terms of resource
consumption so CPU memory a number of
processes running that sort of thing
and that's a great tool if you have kind
of multi cluster environments or sorry
multi-tenant environments we've got a
lot of people sharing one cluster
you don't want noisy neighbors you want
to keep people isolated and ensure that
they're only using the resources that
are allocated to them admission control
I'll talk a little bit about later as
well but that's a point of extensibility
within kubernetes that allows you to
look at the inbound traffic on the API
server and enact custom rules against it
so you can do things like bring your
business rules in if they're not handled
by some of these other built-in pot
policies then you can enforce them
yourself
and finally pod security policies which
allows you to kind of define what things
are allowed to do these via the host
system and there's a number of kind of
levers and dials there for is Co
policies are really about defining what
you can do in terms of service to
service routing so sto what it does is
injects a an envoy proxy as a sidecar to
all of your services that are running
and then it uses that mesh of proxies to
enforce policies as well as collect
telemetry and so there's a number of
adapters as I said there that allow you
to do things like push your telemetry
out to Prometheus and CRO fauna or
stackdriver
on Google cloud and then you can do
other things like connect with Apogee
api's over G RPC and enforce policy
there and those sidecars also are able
to pick up policies directly from the
clusters which is Co is running on so
you can do things like enforce mutual
TLS which you know is a great thing to
do means that if somebody is in unable
to sniff your traffic it's all encrypted
services service authorization allows
you to do routing and rollouts and so
you can shape your traffic you can move
it you can do kind of Bluegreen
deployments all through a top-level set
of rules and then you've got
fine-grained G RPC controls if you're
doing gr pcs
in between your services so
infrastructure there's a number of
interesting ways you can kind of
provision your infrastructure as code I
mentioned GK on Prem those clusters
including kind of the cider ranges that
they have on Prem the API flags that
you're setting that's all declarative so
you can specify that once you can stamp
out clusters that are all doing things
according to what you'd like it is not a
scenario where you have to have somebody
you know running a command line tool and
and having multiple developers doing
whatever they want as an administrator
it's something you can keep control of
and that g/km prem api as well is able
to control the underlying machines and
so it kind of abstracts away that VMS
and allows you to do things like rolling
updates of the infrastructure so you can
bring you know do a node upgrade scale a
cluster all through a code interface
we're taking some of that declarative
stuff and bringing it to GCP as well in
a kubernetes environment we have a
number of gke customers who need to use
the underlying kind of storage resources
for example on GCP from their kubernetes
cluster today if you've got something
that's backed by a GCP service you've
got to kind of go outside of kubernetes
and go into the GCP api's to do the
provisioning of that infrastructure
we've announced GCP cloud connector and
alpha which is a way for you to do that
directly from the kubernetes api so that
doesn't have full coverage of our API
service today but what it does allow you
to do is some of the manage some of the
resources I've got listed here so that
you can create those things as
kubernetes objects so when you're doing
a deployment of an application that's
backed by say cloud spanner you can come
in and not only do the deployment
directly against the kubernetes api but
you can say I also want a spanner
database to be a deployed alongside this
and that's defined as a kubernetes
resource we used what's called custom
resource definitions which is
extensibility built into the grantees
API and that allows you to define these
things at that layer and
if you're coming in to anthos and you
want to do that you can manage all of
that as a set of kubernetes resources so
that's kind of the the set of things
you're able to do with the stuff that's
shipping with anthos that doesn't
necessarily mean that it's easy to
manage a hybrid kind of multi cloud
setup so I want to talk a little bit
about dealing with scale how you can
scale up from maybe a small footprint
into having something that runs across a
large tech organization where you have
multiple teams of administrators
potentially lots and lots of developers
all working in a fairly fractured hybrid
environment and some of the tools we're
building to make that a little bit
easier on folks so this is kind of a
journey that I see a lot of people go
through when they start with kubernetes
and start with gke is that you know when
you're evaluating something you've got
one Operator one set of policies in one
cluster that's you know kind of step one
and it's fairly easy that intiatives
take your policy set and run a
command-line tool like cube cuddle that
pushes policies to the cluster and you
can keep those on your local hard drive
and because it's you and your cluster
everything's fine
you don't you understand everything
that's going on you're the only person
who has to care but quickly it gets a
little bit more complicated when you
bring in a team of operators when you
have multiple people who are responsible
for managing and kubernetes environment
you can't just have a local set of files
and you can't just have people pushing
them necessarily from their command line
because you can step on each other's
toes one person might be writing over
somebody else's stuff and so that's
where we think a repository is a really
useful tool source control mechanisms
were built specifically for this use
case where people need to collaborate on
code and you can do things like use the
tooling that's built around them to do
code reviews to do static analysis of
that code and to understand who did what
when to roll those things back at cetera
so there's been decades of work on
repository's that's a solved problem for
collaborating on code and we want to use
that for infrastructure as well but it
gets even more complicated when you have
these sort of multi-platform
environments so if you're running on GCP
you're running on prem you're running in
another cloud now you have to deal not
only with collaborating with a bunch of
people in a repository you have to deal
with getting that repository and it's
declarations out to all those clusters
so that the policies that you've written
are actually applied and that's not a
non-trivial problem you could loop
through these things and push the
policies but if that fails you're half
way through that and now you've got one
set of policies in one place and other
set of policies in another these are
distributed environments so people can
come in locally and make changes even if
you do your best to keep them out of
that and keep them through this channel
it's always possible for something to go
down something accidental to happen so
if you're not aware of that or you're
not able to reconcile that you may have
something that's out of scope or out of
policy and you don't even know about it
so dealing with the the collaboration
aspects and the distribution aspects is
something that we wanted to build
tooling around to help folks out I'll
quickly talk about why you might want to
have a bunch of different clusters why
you might end up in this scenario there
are a ton of reasons and they often tend
to be driven by the nature of your
business or the vertical that you're in
these are some of the things that we see
so obviously everybody who's been
operating for a while has legacy
software you might have an ERP system
you might have a catalog database that's
sitting on Prem but you want to do stuff
in the cloud so you're building your new
site in the cloud you've got to have
compute in both environments because the
data gravity or things that just don't
make sense to lift and shift over you
may want local execution so it's not
always possible to do everything in the
cloud particularly if you're dealing
with tons of data if you've got a
factory floor or a warehouse with IOT
stuff running around you probably don't
want to ship up every little last
data up another cloud and you might want
to compute running locally
jurisdictional issues so if you're a
global operator you're gonna have the
need to deal with laws all over the
place that have to deal with data
sovereignty keeping things that are
generated in one place stored in that
place augmenting services you may have a
bunch of stuff that's running on Prem
which you want to take advantage of some
of the great machine learning tools that
they have in the cloud and so you've got
to get data up there
IOT we're running into a number of
retailers who run kubernetes clusters in
every store for things like
point-of-sale systems or telemetry from
various sensors and then bursting right
so you've got things running on Prem
which you want to be able to have
flexible capacity using the cloud so you
may have some you may have all of these
things driving you and where that leads
you is that you end up with a fairly
fractured environment and you need some
kind of glue to bring it back together
not only that but you've got to deal
with compliance so you're you've got an
environment that's growing in complexity
and then you've got an outside
environment that has ever increasing
concerns about governance so that's
things like you know the alphabet soup
of compliance the GDP ours and the
hippos and the the Sox it's things like
government regulations it's also things
like business processes and security it
needs those are getting more and more in
terms of the number of them they are
getting more complicated and the
complexity of your environment is just
making that worse and worse over time
and so we see that and we think an
important solution to that is really
thinking about policies code right
taking the various policies that you
have and turning them into codes so that
you can rein in a little bit of that
complexity and start using compute to
deal with it and so policies code is a
pretty simple idea it's basically you
know the ability to take everything that
you care
as an administrator codify it and then
start running your business processes
and your business rules on top of that
anthos config management is a tool
designed to help with that kind of
principle and so we've got a multi
cluster kind of architecture it scales
to hundreds of clusters even thousands
of clusters because the repository is
really the central piece of it and so
anytime you bring up a new cluster if
you've got anthos config management
installed on it it connects to the the
central repository can pull down the
policies that apply to that particular
cluster and that means that we're
unfairly distributed and so if you have
a cluster in every retail store that's
an environment that we can support it
works on Prem and in the cloud there's
nothing about the service that requires
you to talk to GCP we are going to build
you know ways of pulling in telemetry
ways of managing it through the cloud
but you can run entirely disconnected on
Prem so you can keep your repository on
Prem you can have your clusters on Prem
if you're running with anthos you don't
necessarily have to talk back to the
cloud to get in touch with your repo or
pull down your configurations it is
declarative and continues so by
declarative what I mean is you put your
policies in there as you expect them to
be applied you don't have to wait for
them to be applied you just tell the
system what you want and that's kind of
the kubernetes way and then we take that
declaration we apply it to all the
different API servers and then run in a
continuous loop to ensure that the
system is brought in line with that so
that reconciliation is a constant
process and what it allows you to do is
to find once how things should be and
then hand that off to the controllers
that are running in in the various
clusters to ensure that things are
happening that way and then migrating to
it is fairly simple because we are using
the same format for these policy
definitions as kubernetes it is an open
format it's the format that people are
used to managing the clusters if you're
managing clusters today or you're
managing this do today you can take your
configurations cut and paste them in and
ensure work
how that looks is that we just use get
as a source of truth and so our
repository is more or less a set of
llamó files that are expressing all of
your policies with some you know a
little bit of massaging to ensure that
the policies that need to go to one
place or another are handled and so it
handles all your kubernetes and SEO
resources integrates with your source
control everything is native gamal and
we can plug our validators into kind of
whatever source control system you are
using and run kind of inside the same
workflow that you have for your code
it's all meant to be kind of pluggable
in extensible so you can see on the
right here you know I've got a directory
structure of a repository I'm putting
all of my stuff in namespaces I've got
quota
I've got role bindings and it looks very
much like a repository you might set up
for yourself you're just applying these
things we keep calling so I'll get more
into that when we go into the demo but
that's kind of the basic structure of it
so how that looks inside of a kind of
sample architecture for a hybrid anthos
deployment is that you might have a
policy repository that's sitting in an
on-prem data center and you can put all
of your kubernetes definitions that you
need as an administrator there so things
like access control things like Network
policy pod security policy etc things
like your sto mashed enforcing mutual
TLS now can all go into that policy
store and then you may be running
clusters in the Google cloud platform
you may be running clusters on Prem as
long as you have interconnect set up so
that that looks like a one routable
Network everything can come back and
talk to the policy repository and all of
the clusters that you've got running in
both environments are able to see those
and and pull their stuff down that
interconnect goes down we keep the last
state we continue to enforce those
policies and
any network interruption between those
environments just means that new changes
aren't able to come across but the the
last good state is still there and it's
still being enforced and you can see
kind of we have our kid fig management
operator in both places that's the
system the distributed system that's
running on those clusters and and making
sure that everything is in line and the
fact that it is kind of a distributed
system means that again if there's a
networking outage those processes are
still running and so what this enables
you to do is have defense-in-depth for
the policies that you really care about
and it's really kind of a shift left
sort of mentality for administrative
policies so the flow here when you're
making changes once you have stuff
stored in a given repository is that
anything you wanted to you cut a branch
for it and that's humans cutting a
branch so say you've got an
administrator who wants to add a new
namespace for a development team cut a
branch add that there do a code review
on it push it down but you can also have
machine processes algorithms that are
doing the same thing so if we can do
static analysis on all of your policies
we can make recommendations one of the
things we announced here is our policy
intelligence stuff that we're doing on
Google Cloud that's doing analysis of I
am to look at things like over granting
once we're able to see those things we
can translate them back into changes we
know your current state and code we know
how we think it should be we can send
you a pull request and so there's a
whole set of stuff that you can do once
you're able to do static analysis on
your policies we're just getting started
in that area but I think it's a really
promising Avenue once we can get folks
to start doing stuff in code once you've
got those changes you can validate them
and so you can put all of your business
rules at least those business rules that
you're able to codify into validation so
we ship with validation that looks at
syntax and the correctness of the
repository to ensure that bad configs
malformed config sir are not coming down
but as we continue to develop on top of
this
we're gonna ship more and more
validation to allow you to do things
like bring pluggable business rules and
what that means is that if somebody's in
violation of your corporate policies or
they're doing something that they
shouldn't be doing in terms of changing
Network routing or changing access
controls you can catch that in the
pipeline before it hits your environment
before it goes out to your clusters and
so you can shift kind of from grabbing
those things in auditing every so often
to understanding that you know this is a
bad config up front and we're not gonna
allow you to push that because we're
running say a github check on it that
lets us know that you know this policy
is outside of the guardrails the
administrators have set for it that's
going through code review as well right
so teams of administrators now can
collaborate you can kind of have two
people who have to turn the key on major
policies you can see who reviewed it you
can make changes you can do all of that
before it hits the production
environment and then you can also
enforce things at the deployment stage
so admission control to block things
from the clusters you can use the same
logic invalidation against the API so
even if something comes through this
process you can stop it from hitting the
API and stop us from sinking it
reconciliation and auditing still allow
you to kind of guard against drift on
those clusters so if somebody comes in
and makes a local change that's out of
spec you can come in and overwrite that
kind of immediately instead I've talked
about admission control here so another
project that we're working on an
open-source is it's called gatekeeper
gatekeeper is an admission controller
that we are planning on you know
including and helping folks manage in
concert with a lot of this stuff the key
thing about gatekeepers and admission
controllers that uses the open policy
agent which is a CN CF project and open
policy agent is effectively a policy
evaluation engine it takes a set of
policies expressed in code that anybody
can write and will enforce them wherever
it goes so what
keeper does is wrap that in the kind of
infrastructure it needs to be run as a
mission controller and then allows you
to define as a cooper Nettie's resource
any policy you want to be evaluated
against things that are going to hit the
API server so an example of that might
be label enforcement on deployments if
you need all of your deployments to have
particular labels or you need them to
have a label you can say look if you're
you're gonna deploy and you're gonna
deploy this kind of image it needs to
have this particular label or we're not
going to accept it and and those label
rules may be specific to you and you can
kind of program them in there so gate
keeper comes with a kind of kubernetes
interface to push standard rules but it
also has a programming language that
allows you to write those yourself so
let's jump into a demo here I'll show
you a little bit about how we run just
give me a second to log into my machine
okay can we bring up the demo so what
I'm gonna do here is show you just a
simple deployment of any osteo
application it's called the book info
application it's the kind of demo is the
other thing you may have seen it a few
places on the floor here it's available
in the sto Docs as an example I'm just
gonna play around with some of the
policies here show you what that looks
like in a code repository make a couple
changes and what we'll go look at that
live so what I have here is a tea mug
session on the left is where I'm gonna
be running all my commands it's all
scripted but it's all running live on
the right I've got my local file system
so I have a copy of a repository that
I'm hosting up and github there and at
the bottom I've got a couple of watches
and those watches are on live clusters
running on gke I'm running on two but
everything I'm doing here you could run
on thousands of clusters if you wanted
to we've got a watch here just looking
at some pods so you'll be able to see
them coming up as I'm making changes in
the repository so I'm going to set my
cube cuttle to look at a particular
cluster and I'm gonna bring in all of
the policies that I need for my
application this is the local filesystem
here this is our repository format for
CSP config management sorry anthos
config management we've got clusters
cluster scoped resources at the top so
I've got a pod security policy in there
that's ensuring that my deployments are
only able to do certain things against
the host environment I've got a cluster
role there for service deployers that
allows me to define on a namespace per
namespace level who should be allowed to
deploy within that namespace so that's
something I can hand out to individual
groups of users or individual users and
then I have all my namespace level
resources so this is where all the
deployments are defined I've got two
namespaces here miscellaneous and
services and then I have an admin role
binding that I want to apply across both
of them you notice that admin role
binding sits in the directory structure
above both of those namespaces what we
allow in our
soory format is kind of copy down
inheritance so if you have a resource
that you want to be spread across
multiple namespaces we can use the
hierarchy of the directory structure to
kind of inherit that down we can also
apply to a group of namespaces so if you
don't have a hierarchy and you want to
just use sets of namespaces to apply
policies and we have a mechanism for
that in addition you can apply policies
to individual clusters or individual
sets of clusters based on label
selection so this allows you to say okay
I have one set of policies that need to
be everywhere or I have some policies
that just need to be in these namespaces
or just these clusters or some
combination thereof I've got all my
services for the the book info app here
in the services namespace and then I've
got a miscellaneous namespace up there
that just has a namespace definition and
a quota attached to it right now so it's
empty there's nothing running there so
let's go look at what we've got here so
I'm gonna add this to my repository you
see nothing's running at the moment this
is all local it's just a set of policies
in my file system I'm gonna make a
commit up to my git repository and add
all of these files and push that live so
this is going up to github pushing all
of those policies there and updating the
repository and then I've got the
clusters watching that and you can see
already I've got pods initializing on
cluster to cluster ones a little bit
behind but it's catching up and so now
I've got all of the services that I need
it for my micro services application to
run I can go take a look at the cluster
so I'm gonna go look at the role
bindings in the miscellaneous namespace
so as you can see there's no role
binding applied directly to that
namespace all it's getting is an
inherited role binding from the
directory above it but if you look at it
live on the cluster there's that admin
role binding that showed up 35 seconds
ago and so this is great for things like
administrative role bindings this
inheritance and that you can set that
once and apply it and make sure that
every
one of your namespaces in kind of a
multi-tenant cluster has access for your
administrators it's not just for role
binding so you can also do things like
apply a network policy so if you have
the requirement that you want everybody
to be strictly defining pod to pod
traffic so they say this service is only
allowed to talk to that service you can
put an empty network policy at the the
root of your repository and have it
inherited down to all of your namespaces
what that will do is by default cut off
all traffic outside of the namespace and
it will force your developers to come in
and define it explicitly on top of that
so it's different ways that you can use
that to kind of simplify your policy
application not have to be repetitive
and doing things namespace by namespace
one of the other nice things we do is
guard against people coming in and doing
destructive things against
administrative policies so that's an
admin role binding if I'm an
administrator I probably want that there
I need to be able to get in there if
somebody came in and decided that they
were gonna delete my sre admin role
binding from their namespace so they
could lock out the admins that would be
bad I've got administrative access on
this cluster so I can go do that so
let's go do something destructive let's
delete that role Barney so now you know
myoh Suri's can't get back in but if we
go look at it on the cluster you can see
its back seven seconds ago which is just
about when I applied it we came back in
and rewrote it and so if you come in and
you try to affect one of these policies
that the administrator has applied we
can automatically reconcile that back to
whatever's in the repository so
let's go look at the quota in the
miscellaneous namespace so this is
resource quota that I'm applying here so
in this namespace I put in a policy that
says you can only have one pod you can
only use 10% of a virtual CPU it only
gets 100 Meg's of memory if I want to
say deploy a pod here I can do that as
long as I'm within that quota I'm gonna
deploy it's kind of cut off on the left
there but it is a a instance of busybox
that sleeps this is not a particularly
useful thing to deploy in your clusters
but just for an example you can notice
if you see just at the top there I'm
deploying a pod but I happen to have
misspelled it it says PD instead of pod
up on the left so this won't work if I
try to push it to the cluster if I put
it in the repository you'll never get
sink down I'm just writing it locally so
that's not a problem yet as I said one
of the things we ship with is a
validation so we have a command line
tool we call Nomos this can run is a git
hook it can run as a check say in github
or some other you know source tooling
system so that every time you push
something into the repository you can
validate that it's syntactically correct
that it's correct based on the format of
the repository and that you're not going
to be trying to push bad configs if I
run that against this pod definition it
throws an error unless you know no
matches for kind PUD in in version v1 so
let's go fix that I'm coming here and
add my missing Oh and then save it
and so if I run that validation again it
passes clean with no errors so now I'm
ready to go and that's a clean pod so
let's go take a look at the the running
services here I'm gonna figure out where
my service is actually running here by
looking at the gateway to Sto I'm gonna
pick this up and we can go look at it
and see this is the github repository
where I'm running right now if i refresh
that you can see all the resources got
here so let's go look at our sto service
doesn't look like it's running
seems like I've got a networking problem
here try one more thing
so it looks like my pods are running but
it is not routable sure if that's my
local networking causing problems or not
alright well we'll move on got running
pods we've got no network connectivity
so one of the things I can do with this
is change some of the routing rules in
my micro-services mash so the sto allows
you to define what we call virtual
services virtual services can take
traffic that's coming in through the
Gateway and route it into individual
pods
I've got virtual services defined here
for the various things that are running
in my micro services architecture and if
you look you can see I've got a review
service here
that's routing 100% of my traffic to the
v1 pod of reviews there are actually
three different versions of reviews
running on each of these clusters so if
I want I can do an upgrade in place by
routing the traffic from v1 to v2
because those are running now in a real
life environment I probably would do
this very slowly right I would take it
and I maybe have a canary branch where I
had a cluster that was pointing at a
canary branch of my policies make that
change in the canary branch go take a
look at it live make sure it was working
I may decide to route just a very small
percentage of traffic there go look at
my monitoring and make sure that that
was working you can do all of that
directly through this kind of code based
interface but since we're short on time
let's just do it live in production so
I'm going to upgrade this to v2 and I'm
gonna save it and that's all I need to
do to upgrade that service now what that
does is it changes to a new version of
reviews that actually calls the ratings
system so it's going to bring in
additional information to the the book
info app and we can make that change and
push it up
okay so that's going out to github and
now if we look at the live cluster it's
still looking at v1 but it it just
flipped over so you can see where it
says subset down there and now it's
pointing at v2 so we've changed our
routing rules live on all of our
clusters if I go look at this other
cluster hopefully my service came up
there so let's see that one and see if
it's live
okay one is you ain't bad so this is my
other cluster if you had seen it before
when it was working on cluster one you
would have seen that there were no star
ratings there star ratings now because
I've upgraded that version of the
micro-service and it is pulling from the
ratings service because of the routing
rules I've changed and these routing
rules have changed on both those
clusters simultaneously if I were to
enroll ten clusters or 20 clusters I
could make that change across all of
them or I can make that change across a
subset of them you know depending on
kind of what I want to do there one
other good thing about having a git
repository is that it's transactional so
everything that I've done here was done
in a particular commit and I can roll
those back at any time if I want to undo
all of my changes and get back to a
clean state that I know is ok I can just
delete everything I added locally in my
environment and then push it back up to
the cluster and so effectively what that
does is revert all of the commits that I
made removes all the files that I added
and goes back to the state that we were
at when we started the demo and if I
push that up it's going to clean
everything out that I build it's gonna
clean out all of those routing rules
it's gonna clean out all of these pods
it's gonna restore my state back to
where I wanted it and if we look we
should stay those pods start to
terminate and there they go
so this is gonna roll everything back
bring it back to an entirely clean state
where I've got naked clusters so that is
my demo you go back to the slides please
so that's ESP community management
Antos config management I'll get used to
that eventually if you're interested
it's available now to ant those
customers so if you're participating if
you were participant those beta you're
signing up for anthos this comes along
with it it works on Prem today it works
in the cloud today if you're interested
in getting early access because you're a
gke customer we are going to make it
available to GK customers and so you can
sign up here if you're interested in
that and I'll whitelist you for that and
bring you in we do expect to make it
available on GK as well for folks who
are kind of purely cloud based and
working with us in GCP we're out of time
I'll hang out if folks want to talk
thank you very much
[Music]